i think this is a really good example of
a difficult
figure that's controversial that people
bring up to me a lot and
you interviewed twice which is curtis
yarvin yeah manchester united manchester
small
aka manchester small bug which is his
pseudonym that he goes by
is his blog can you tell me about who
he is sure why is he interesting one of
his ideas are interesting
well he briefly he invented the concept
the red pill
so curtis mentions moldblock had a blog
called unqualified reservations you can
still find it
online it's very verbose he writes
at length very very bright
his perspective is very heretical
so a lot of things that we take for
granted in our liberal democracy
uh he regards as not only incorrect
which is downright absurd
and does not he does not take what many
people
view as the basis of american discourse
as the basis for his thought so
when you're starting with someone who is
basically repudiating
uh kind of the western world view or not
the western world view like the american
milieu
uh a lot of people are gonna of course
regard him as dangerous or uh
someone who is verboten um he's a very
bright
person um why is he such a toxic figure
because if you are blue pill if you are
the guardians of what is
acceptable discourse then you have to
make sure your forts
are secured and that any figure outside
of this acceptable discourse
has to be marginalized and regarded as
radioactive as possible you don't want
to let in
these kind of ideas that would be
destructive to your hegemony well so
let's
dig into it so like he i've read a few
things
by him but then i hear that
in a bunch of places him being called a
racist a white supremacist
yeah neo-fascist so on
i go to his wikipedia yeah there's a
view on race
section let me let me read it
okay jarvin's opinions have been
described as racist
with his writings interpreted as
supportive of slavery
including the belief that whites have
higher iqs than blacks for genetic
reasons
jarvan himself maintains that he's not a
racist
because while he doubts that quote all
races are equally smart
the notion quote that people who score
higher on iq tests and in some sense
superior human beings is
quote creepy he also disputes being an
outspoken advocate for slavery
though he has argued that some races are
more suited for slavery than others
quote it should be obvious that although
i'm not a white suprem
white nationalist i am not exactly
allergic to the stuff
jarvan wrote in a post that linked
approvingly of
i don't know these people steve saylor
yeah he's from jared taylor and
other racial lists yeah so okay so like
one of my questions is we can let me
just say one sentence
in the same way that you had you
mentioned that guy earlier who was
defending some aspects of communism
and that is in some context acceptable
when you think about it's like
this should be radioactive right the
fact that he is engaging with these
ideas
uh in any thing other than this has to
be reputed at all costs
is what renders him to a large extent
racist that's really interesting
so there are some topics you can be
nuanced
nuanced and some not and communism is
still a topic that you
can be nuanced about right it's
difficult but you can be
uh race and this like talking about
slavery and
iq differences based on race is a topic
that
i guess is radioactive to a degree where
you can't even say anything
even if it's like nuanced or
not even like making a point it's like
touching it right as you make another
point
and understandably because you can
understand that i'm going to steal man
the
their point because you can understand
the point it's like you're just talking
about hitler
once this foot gets in the door that
some people are
inherently slaves or some people are
inherently better than others
it really quickly you know collapses so
that would be their perspective
but that's what like if i were to give
criticism of his
but let me just say one more thing
racist is also used to describe alex
jones
alex doesn't talk about race racist is a
shorthand
for a certain percentage of the
population to let you know
do not bother investigating this person
any further
yeah they're off limits definitely
racism and sexism is a thing that's not
used to shut down conversation that's
quite absurd
uh by by a small percent of the point
jarrod taylor and steve saylor
jared taylor interviewed him from my
book he would be regarded
in any sense as a racist what's the
difference between racist and racialist
so racialists i mean this is splitting
hairs and now i'm gonna be all
radioactive
jarrod taylor runs something called
amaran and this is
i mean his perspective is that there are
inherent differences to the races
and you cannot live side by side uh um
well whites and blacks should not be
living uh by the way for people who
don't know this is
out of context that you have written a
great book
that includes some of these concepts
called the new right which is not
includes these concepts but talks about
yeah
well it's more about the growth of the
comm the community
uh around the uh that's the outrage and
all those kinds of
the world right so and his point about
iq
it's like if you had a population the
dutch
right i think they're the tallest people
on earth and if you said well the dutch
are the best people on earth why because
they're the tallest it's like you're
a crazy person so if someone is scoring
low an
individual on an iq test that means
they're somehow a lower quality person
well maybe one very specific aspect
but i mean if they're a good human being
i've got friends who are like you all my
friends are like you frankly compared to
me
sound like trump they're first that's
how you choose well i don't have any
other choices no one's gonna be at my
level
well you're the you're the smartest
person since abraham lincoln that i've
that i've ever seen unlike him i
actually am honest
so so he is someone who very much
swims in heretical ideas
aristotle here's another thing like if
you bring up that aristotle
said that some people are born to be
slaves he wasn't speaking about race he
just meant people's
souls h.l mencken who was a great
heretic
and uh early to 20th century figure
uh one of his quotes that i say all the
time which people have seen a lot in
this past year
that the average man does not want to be
free he merely wants to be safe
that i think is speaking i don't know
what i am not familiar
uh with what mullbug's saying about
slavery because his writing is ponderous
but that certainly is something i think
that is undeniable that i think more
people are realizing there's a large
percent of the population
that is actively disinterested in
freedom and the more responsibilities it
entails
well i mean really just the word slavery
if you want to make some kind of point
or even think about
the topic outside the context of this is
a horrible thing that happened in the
united states history
and other countries history let's be
clear this is i mean very important and
there's slavery going on today and
a lot of people argue that uh sex
trafficking and all those kinds of
things i mean there's there's
atrocities going on today that you know
uh talking about it in a way that's not
immediately saying this is the most
horrible thing that happened ever
you know it's something i think about
a lot is like if i want to say something
controversial
i should do so with skill with care
and only about things i care about well
here's where i would disagree
i not when i say things i often say
things that are controversial
or i will say uncontroversial things in
a controversial
way because it's a useful mechanism to
alienate
people you don't want around you because
if there are people who are going to be
shocked by certain topics like we should
have entered world war
ii like even as a hypothesis they just
clutch their pros they're like oh you
want the holocaust to happen
i can't discuss most things with you
because you're not interested in having
a conversation you're interested in your
emotional response yeah i think i see
things differently maybe this is
a bit of a devil's advocate but what in
at least the modern
discourse of like twitter and social
media and so on
i find that if you do that you're not
actually
uh removing the people that are not
thoughtful and
kind and so on you're actually
attracting loud people
like a small number of them they come
over and start yelling at you start
yelling
they're basically ruin the party by
showing up and just screaming and so all
the thoughtful people leave well that's
why
you have to be a very heavy blocker you
have to block people on twitter because
you have to cultivate your audience
and have them like a lot of times people
come at me i don't care then they'll
start
attacking members of my audience and
then i'm like dang i gotta block them
because they've won this one
because i can't have that
yeah i don't know i un
necessarily provoking people feels um
it's it's it's you this is beta testing
you try to break the system and see what
works you put as much pressure as
possible
this is very much computer stuff that
you should be able to appreciate
the point being when you have a program
you're trying to intentionally sit there
and do them as many mistakes see what go
wrong right is that not
common yeah yeah so you're saying that
that's a way to see
communication with the world as you say
something
uncontroversial in a controversial way
and that blocks people
that or or does it trigger them do they
roll their eyes you know what is going
to be their emotional response
are they going to start yelling the
problem is the reason i can't
think like this or i can't because i'm
not sure about the points i'm trying to
make
always like i'm not always 100 sure that
i'm right about things like so
i'm in being thoughtful i'm afraid that
i'll turn off with an ineloquently
phrased
or even incorrect statement i will do
damage that can't be
undone in terms of having a good
conversation about a topic
so i want to be very careful about like
i'm not saying afraid fear is not what
i'm talking about i think
fear is is uh like not saying something
out of fear is
at the core of the media the problems of
the world today
but i'm just saying be say stuff with
care
if i'm going to touch race as a topic it
feels like
you really should be deeply
first have a point to make like you
really care about a point you want to
make
and second think deeply about how to say
that point in a way that communicates
the best and and touching
i would say listen i've
i've uh on your show which is which is
great
i mean i'd like to say thank you for
having me just small bugs you are
welcome
that's the uh that's the name
of the show thank you for having me a
couple of times it's it's great to sort
of
get him to in this loose way to to talk
about different kinds of stuff
i don't think we talk about race at all
so no no no but i'm just
bringing it back to what you were asking
which is if you read the wikipedia
the perspective is going to be this guy
talks about slavery constantly
where it's completely disproportionate
to his work but even on your show
you can tell even not outside of the
race stuff that he's not
ultra careful about he's not uh
nuanced yeah he's not afraid to say
something
just like i would say let me just
criticize him my face is not you this is
me
carelessly say something controversial
right
like i'm not saying he doesn't go like
you know that makes him
it's a very different thing than uh uh
somebody who on purpose says something
controversial stuff
uh like milo not annopolis sorry
i forgot milo whatever his name is yeah
which is really nice to see that he's a
genuine person who's thoughtful he
doesn't
mean to but he just cares carelessly
seems to say
things that uh i feel like damaged the
rest of his body of work
i can't really speak for him but i would
guess his point is
once you're swimming in this kind of
world view
you're going to be anathema already
so there's no pleasing these people so
why bother trying yeah i think that's a
deeply that's a that's a black pill way
of
seeing the world it's not blackfield at
all because it's a cynical way
like these people so like it's it's
saying that
you're it's a very kind of way of
thinking like i'll say whatever i want
whoever comes along with me no you just
earlier said yourself that
race racism has been weaponized as a way
to shut down conversation
so i think his perspective would be i am
so outside the mainstream
in my worldview that i know i'm going to
be called racism
racist so there's no point in trying to
be nuanced
because i'm already going to get the
scarlet letter yeah i just disagree with
that because
for example i'm one i am one person that
he turned off
okay by his carelessness and i think i
should be a good target i should be
saying i think that's fair and
i'm just like he it's very convenient to
think that there's ridiculous people out
there which they are sure
who call everybody racist and sexist
currently and then
you can't please them so i'm not even
gonna try
no but there's like this gray area of
people sure that i don't listen to the
outrage culture whatever that i don't
this wikipedia article
means nothing to me like i i'm not going
to right
i'm more i'm just seeing this careless
person and if he's going to be careless
about uh like race like this
i feel like if i walk along with him
long enough
i'm going to catch the carelessness i'm
going to lose
like i'll defend your perspective there
than you can yeah
this is happening this is good i'm
taking notes i talked to eric weinstein
after you guys talked about me on your
show when i was weinstein
we had a good conversation he invited me
on his show that would be an amazing
conversation
and we got on the phone and his concern
fairly
he goes i don't want you to come on my
show for the purposes of clowning me
and i would never do that yeah it's
it would never he might not be aware of
who that's why he wants to feel me out
he's like you know when he hears troll
it can mean a lot of different things
and i
we had a very conversation and very much
was very clear that's not where the
conversation would go
but i think when you are going to be on
someone's show
there is a responsibility that they're
not going to have to pay a cost
for having you as their guests so if
you're perc if you were put off
by how he was in that live stream or two
i did like i understand where you're
coming from i think he's very very
bright
but you have a very you have a different
audience than i do and you're going for
something different than i am no no like
in my in just a sense of
you wouldn't feel safe with him yeah i
wouldn't feel safe with him but he's
he's born alive for me i think
i think i would like to actually talk to
him one day uh
alex jones has crossed the other line
for me well you could do what you can do
with me
tape the episode and never release it
no it's it's one of those things will be
uh when there's finally
they'll make a history channel
documentary about you and i
and how it all went wrong like the cult
that we started and everybody killed
themselves
and uh there's a
we'll release it then because it'll be
like unseen footage this is how it
started
it would be black and white
in a basement somewhere in new york yeah
yeah my mother's basement
[Laughter]
ah this explains so much okay
you